this video was posted this week on wall
street bets
a reddit forum dedicated to discussing
stock and options trading
this little rocket represents gme the
stock ticker for video game retailer
gamestop
for weeks users of the subreddit have
been encouraging each other to scoop up
shares
and make bullish wagers on the stock in
less than a month
gme rose from under twenty dollars a
share to well over three hundred dollars
on some days
before falling on thursday after brokers
placed restrictions on
trading wall street has been totally
stunned by what's happened with gamestop
this has basically never happened before
alexander osiepovic
covers futures and stock exchanges for
the wall street journal and has explored
the forces behind gamestop's dramatic
swings
gamestop has become a battleground
between small investors who are banding
together on
online forums like reddit and
professional investors
who are shorting the stock or betting
that will fall here's what's going on
with gamestop
wall street bets is one of the most
popular forums on reddit
it's a place where people get together
share trading ideas and go after
particular stocks in a kind of
coordinated fashion
they can cause a big run-up in that
stock's price in recent weeks
investors on wall street bets have
targeted gamestop's short sellers
who saw the company as overpriced and
were betting the shares would fall
the wall street bets crowd was buying up
shares and betting the opposite
causing the stock to go on a wild ride
behind that is
a couple of things one of them is
momentum trading
that's when people chase games they see
a stock is going up they buy more of it
because they'll
likely keep going up but while the rise
might have appeared to be as simple as
average investors
buying shares and pumping up the price
it also had to do
with options options are contracts that
allow investors to buy
or sell a stock at a specified price
either on
or until a specified date it has gotten
a lot easier and cheaper for people to
trade options over the past few years
now the world is your trading floor
commissions have come down
and brokers have invested a lot of time
and effort into making
easy to use interfaces to allow people
to buy and sell them and even do complex
strategies
options trading volumes set a record
last year averaging just under 30
million contracts a day
this year that number is over 40 million
options come in two forms put options
confer the right to sell shares under
specified terms
and call options confer the right to buy
them
many of the wall street's bets users
were buying call options to bet that the
price would rise
look at the market on tuesday january
26th for example
gamestop closed at just under 148
dollars
at that moment call options to buy
gamestop shares at 200
a piece by friday were trading at just
19. a share
if gamestop rallied the price of the
options might have risen
and call holders would have been able to
sell these options for a quick profit
the question is why were the shares
surging when much of the action was in
options it's because when an investor
buys a call option
someone else has to sell it to them
typically an electronic trading firm
that buys and sells stocks
when they sell the investor the call
option they often hedge their bet
by purchasing shares of the stock in
question
gamestop options trading volumes
exploded during the past two weeks
especially for call options which drove
brokers to buy
more of the stock driving it up even
further
this dynamic isn't just playing out with
gamestop traders at wall street bets
moved on to amc blackberry and nokia as
well
amid soaring shares on january 28th
popular online brokerages
including robinhood and interactive
brokers group restricted access
to trading high-flying stocks including
game stop
shares plunged trading a stock like
gamestop in a situation like this is
extremely risky
if you are dupe playing with this stuff
you are playing with fire
it's unclear if the authorities have any
means reigning the sin
wall street bets users called foul some
pledging to find other ways to
participate in the market
regardless of the chaos it causes